RETO MEIER: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier, and
welcome to "This Week in
Android Development,"
October 29, 2012.
A lot of interesting things
happened in Android
development last week, and
we've got a lot more
planned this week.
But you don't care about any
of that because today we
launched new hardware.
Not even the imminent threat
of Hurricane Sandy could
prevent the release of the best
kept secrets of the year.
Today Andy Rubin peeled back the
veil of absolute secrecy
that has successfully shrouded
Android 4.2 and all the
hardware it's launching with,
including the new 4.7 inch,
320 ppi Nexus 4 smartphone
developed together with LG, or
the incredible 2560 by 1,600,
300 ppi display Nexus 10
tablet developed in partnership
with Samsung.
And of course, the new mobile
data version of the Nexus 7.
All of these shiny new pieces
of consumer electronics will
be available from the Google
Play store on November 13.
Along with the shiny metal and
plastic, we also saw our first
Android 4.2, featuring
Photosphere, gesture typing,
wireless display, and
multi-user support.
"Android Developers Live" last
week saw the final episode of
some of our oldest shows.
Our weekly Android Developer
office hours from Mountain
View will be going on hiatus
while we retool the format, as
will Dan and the "Friday Games
Review." Look for its return
when Dan restocks on headware.
Rest assured that "Android
Design in Action" will
continue each week.
Last week Roman and the guys
looked at shopping list apps
Out of Milk and Grocery IQ.
We'll also be continuing with
our revamped "App Clinic."
We're turning our attention to
more technical depth, with Ian
and I helping to explain not
just what apps should be doing
better, but also showing the
code snippets necessary to
make it happen.
Our goal is to help create a
collection of awesome apps
that we're calling
pure Android.
Check out the video for
more details on
what we've got planned.
And if you want your app
reviewed on the app clinic, be
sure to nominate it using this
Trello board and vote on the
apps and app categories you'd
like us to review in future
weeks while you're there.
This week, we'll be looking at
travel assistance apps just in
time for the upcoming
holiday season.
As always, you can find the
complete schedule for this
week's live shows at Google
Developers Live.
That's developers.googl
e.com/live/android.
Today's live wallpaper was
Paperland, brought to you by
Joko interactive, and
I knew were trouble
when you walked in.
My name is Reto Meier,
thanks for watching.